the favorite to win the men's title at
the australian open novak djokovic
returned to his native serbia this
morning after losing a final appeal in
court holly williams reports on the
decision to force the nine-time champion
to leave australia for refusing to be
vaccinated against covet it's game set
and match to the australian government
in its battle with the world's number
one men's tennis player deported after
11 days of legal wrangling and anger
from his fellow serbians
novak djokovic ignored questions from
journalists flanked by his team as he
left the country
how are you feeling mr chocolate
i'm gonna put the phone down please i am
extremely disappointed said djokovic in
a statement adding he was uncomfortable
that the focus of the past weeks was on
him
the australian government said it
cancelled his visa because djokovic's
presence could lead to an increase in
anti-vaccination sentiment and even
civil unrest
australia has one of the highest
vaccination rates in the world nearly 93
percent of those age 16 and over an
opinion poll yesterday showed 71 percent
of australians wanted djokovic deported
anyone in australia who's not vaccinated
can't go to work
can't go to a restaurant probably can't
walk in the gate here today so why
should anyone be able to work with
unvaccination in australia full stop
australia requires everyone entering the
country to be vaccinated or have a
medical exemption djokovic had an
exemption because of a recent covet
infection but it sparked outrage in
australia apparently prompting the
government to act
seeing him just waltz in was a real slap
in the face to people who have family
members that are stuck overseas brendan
crew is a reporter for network 10
australia
vaccine mandates definitely could be
career ending for sports people like
novak djokovic if they stick to their
guns and don't get vaccinated
just this morning france said that based
on current rules unvaccinated players
will not be able to compete at the
french open in may most tennis players
have been diplomatic about djokovic's
problems but rafael nadal said yesterday
quote the australian open is much more
important than any player
gail
i heard him say that thank you holly he
also said that the australian open will
still be good even without novak
djokovic
i'm glad the tournament will continue
thank you very much holly williams in
london thanks a lot